So let's talk a little bit about
vision in your visual field.
So as you know, you've got two eyes,
well you started out with two eyes for
most of us.
Each eye is about 160 degrees and
they overlap at about 120 degrees,
which means, if you do the math,
it means you have about 200
degrees total field of view.
Different animals are different,
by the way.
Some animals, the ones that are prey,
and supposed predator.
Their eyes are back here.
So they have a wider field of view,
and that is they can see more behind,
further behind them,
which you might want to do if
you're worried about a predator.
But of course,
it means you have less stereo vision.
But remember, we were talking
about nerves coming out and
crossing this area
called the optic chiasm?
Let's take a look at that
a little more carefully.
The human vision system does,
well you're probably quite familiar
with your motor control system, right?
That the left part of your brain
controls the right arm, and
the right part of your
brain controls the left.
And if you have a stroke on the left
side of your of your brain you'll,
you'll lose some motor function
also some sensory function.
Well, you probably didnt
stop to think about that
the eyes have a tricky problem, right?
So the stuff that I see over here is
seen in this eye and in this eye.
And the stuff I see over here is
seen in this eye and in that eye.
How does the brain deal with that?
Well, the way it does it is,
it actually splits the eyeball in half,
in terms of where
the projections come from.
So here we see the right visual field,
which is looked at by this
left side of the eye.
Which is the temporal side of the left
eye and the nasal side of the right eye.
Tho, both of those come in
through the optic chiasm
going to the left side of your brain.
So the left side of your
brain is looking at
this stuff over here on the right
in both of the eyes, okay?
And likewise, the right side of my right
eye and the right side of my left eye,
which is looking at the stuff
on the left-hand side,
is projected to the right-hand
side of my brain.
And so just the same way that your
sensation on your right arm is in your
left brain, the sensation in your right
visual field is at your left brain.
Also in this other view of the sort
of the projection of the optic
system into the brain, you can see
these other structures, right?
So we get here to
the lateral geniculate,
again on both sides,
project into the superior colliculus.
And here you can see that there
are these projections out
to this whole area of visual
cortex which is in the back.
And we'll look at that.
One of the implications of
this right half, left half,
the right part of your brain looking
at the left half, vice versa, is if,
if you have a some sort of the
degeneracy or stroke or something, and
let's say you were to lose some
function on one side of your brain
you'd experience what's referred to as
here it's written, hemifield neglect.
'Kay, and what that means is that,
so you've had a damage, let's say,
to the left side of your brain,
the whole right side area would
just sort of not be there.
And what's interesting, and, and we'll
see an example of this a minute when we
talk about blind spots and stuff, you
don't feel like there's a hole there.
You just feel like this
is my field of view.
I don't actually know what's over there.
Okay, so it's not like right now
I feel there's a hole back here.
Despite what my wife says,
there's no hole in the back of my head,
I don't think.
But I just don't, I just know that
I can't see what's back there.
Well what happens is if your brain
sort of starts not knowing what's over
here, it just kind of, you know,
it just doesn't worry about it.
You know and in fact, what will happen
is that it'll fill in some stuff for
a little bit, kind of like you do
with the rest of your visual field.
We'll talk about that in a minute too.
But, but I don't want you to get a sense
that you would feel like there was
a great big black hole
sitting over there.